PROFESSOR: Two particles is
interesting in many cases.
But in order to see
what really is happening
and how much structure you
have to go to more than two
particles.
Two particles is a
little too special.
So we need to go
beyond two particles
and see what happens
with this operator.
So I'll do that.
So we'll add more particles.
So let's do that.
So if you have n particles,
n particles, capital n,
we can consider
also permutations.
And how many permutations
are you going to have?
You're going to have n
factorial permutations.
And notation of Hilbert
space, n factorial permutation
operators.
So why you say n factorial?
Because a permutation is a
reordering of your n objects.
And therefore, in order
to define the reordering,
you must decide which object
is going to be the new first.
You have your n objects there.
So you have n choices to pick
a first and n minus 1 choices
to be a second, n minus 2.
So n factorial is the
number of permutations.
The permutations form a group.
So the permutations
of n objects form
this symmetric group s capital
n with n factorial elements.
Just like you study
the group su2 of two
by two unitary matrices,
or the group so3 of three
dimensional rotations in space.
The permutation
group is the group
that deserves a lot of study.
It's a finite discrete group.
It's not a continuous
group of transformations.
It's discrete transformations.
And they do funny things.
So we need to
understand this group so
let's describe the notation
of what is a permutation.
Suppose you have n
equal 4, four particles.
So a given state is
represented by a, b, c, d.
And you could say this is the
first particle, second, third,
and fourth.
And these are the states.
And now we're going to
write the perturbation.
The best thing, I think, is
just do an example, p3142.
So a permutation now has capital
n labels, so four labels.
And this is a permutation
acting on this state.
Remember the 2-1
permutation exchange.
The state in 2 was put in 1.
The state in 1 was put in 2.
Here is the instruction.
So the instruction is, put in
position one the third state.
So here it says 3,
so the third state
goes into the first position.
So that's the first position.
The first state goes
into the second position.
The fourth state goes
into the third position.
The third in this here.
So the third position
is now occupied
by the fourth state, d.
And the second state goes
into the fourth position, b.
So this is the way we are
going to define permutations.
People define them
in different ways
and you have to be sure
you know what it means.
But I'll right this.
This means put third
object in first position.
Here the second one, let's
write put first object
in second position.
It's nice to have this notation
because now you can understand
how the group works.
A group of
transformations is a set
of elements that
can be multiplied.
There is an identity.
And things have
inverses as well.
So permutations have inverses.
If you rearrange the
objects in one way,
you can rearrange them back.
So for example, what
would be the inverse
of this permutation?
I will try to figure out
what is the inverse of p3142.
So I look at this
thing and I think
of what is the instruction
that I must put in order
to rearrange back this series.
And I say, well, I must put the
second back in position one.
So there should be a p2 here.
I should put the
fourth in position two.
And then I should put the
first in position three.
First in position three.
And I should put the
third in position four.
So I claim that is the
inverse of this operator,
p213 is the inverse of this.
So you can check it.
Again, p2413 times p3142,
you just do it on a, b, c, d.
Well, the first one, you
already know, is 2413,
is put the third in one.
Put the first in two.
Put the fourth in three.
And put the second in fourth, b.
And then it says, put
the second first--
so that's an a.
Put the fourth, second, b.
Put the first, third, c.
And put the third, fourth, d.
So it's back to
the original one.
So indeed, it is the inverse.
So you can write your
permutations and play with them
and figure out how to
multiply any two permutations.
More generally, we'll write
the permutation as follows.
Suppose you have more generally
a permutations [INAUDIBLE]
with some index alpha,
collective index alpha,
that says how the
integers, 1 up to n,
are rearranged into alpha of 1,
alpha of 2, up to alpha of n.
So think of a permutation
and thinking n integers
and rearranging them.
So the first one,
the new first index
is going to be alpha
of 1, alpha of 2.
And alpha is a rule that takes
the n integers from 1 to n
and reshuffles them.
So if you have a state--
so this is a simple
thing because then
if you have a p alpha, this
alpha means really p alpha1,
alpha2, all these things.
Be alpha1, alpha2,
alpha3, alpha4.
If those act on u1 1, u2
2, up to u n, capital n, n,
what does it give you?
Well, it says here
that you should
put the 1 that has alpha 1
here on the first position.
So you should put,
first, the u alpha1.
And then you should
put next the u alpha2.
And all the way up
to the u alpha n.
That's in formulas,
the rule that I
was giving you above there.
It tells you how to move the
state from one to the other.
You see, if alpha1
was 3, it would
correspond to take the state
u3 and putting it first.
So it's like that.
So whatever alpha 1,
is whatever number,
that state must be pulled
into the first [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, so let's just think
a little about an example
because it starts
getting interesting.
So let's do three particles
for a little while, just
to see what it is.
So three particles, n equal 3.
So what are the
permutation operators?
You would say p123 is what?
Put the first particle first,
the second particle second,
the third particle third.
Doesn't do anything.
That is the identity.
So that's the identity element.
But then you could
cycle them, p321, p231.
These are two more elements.
This should have six elements
because it's 3 factorial.
And now you have the following
one, p132, for example.
That was not in the list.
You had the p123.
Now you flip this to p132.
If I cycle them, p321,
and p213, these are it.
The middle one, 312, yes.
I was supposed to be cycling
them, 312 and 231, yes.
Otherwise I would
have repeated that.
Good eye.
OK, so these are our operators.
And these ones
are kind of funny.
They are simpler ones.
Please look at them.
This operator says put the first
particle in the first position.
So the first particle
is left unchanged.
But the 3 and 2 are permuted.
So people sometimes write this.
They say, this permutation
operator is just
a single transposition,
32 or 23.
These two are transposed and
the first is left invariant.
So this can be written as
a single transposition.
In this permutation operator,
a 2 is left invariant.
The second state is copied
to the second position.
But the 1 and 3 are
exchanged, so this
is a transposition of 1 and 3.
And in this last
permutation operator,
the third state
is left invariant
on the third position.
Nevertheless, the
second is put in first
and the first is put in second.
So it's a 12 transposition.
OK, so the group has broken into
things that are transpositions
and slightly more
complicated things.
Now, let's look at
the transpositions.
So these are transpositions.
OK, what about the
transpositions?
Transpositions are like
the permutation operators
we were doing before
of two particles.
You're just changing
two particles.
You're leaving the
other ones unchanged.
So these transpositions
are Hermitian and unitary.
Positions are
Hermitian and unitary,
just like we had p21 before.
Now here comes the
first statement
that is quite remarkable
about this permutation group.
Any permutation, now we
claim, is the product
of some transpositions.
You see, if somebody gives you
a permutation of n integers,
I think you're convinced that
by changing two at a time,
you can reach that.
So that means that with
transpositions, you can
reach every possible element.
So any-- this is very
important-- any permutation is
the product of transpositions.
And that implies, in a
sense, the main result
that you want from operators
in this Hilbert space.
Since transpositions are
unitary and any permutation
is a product of transpositions,
any permutation is unitary.
So all permutations are unitary.
It's not true that all
permutations are Hermitian.
You see, when you
have the product
of her Hermitian
operators the product
of her Hermitian operators
is not necessarily Hermitian.
You've seen that.
If you have two operators
that are Hermitian,
the order changes.
And the product is not
Hermitian, x and p.
Hermitian operators, the
product is not Hermitian.
So all permutations are
unitary but are not Hermitian.
And the third concept
that comes here
illustrated [INAUDIBLE] also
a very fundamental concept.
We said that any permutation
is a product of transpositions.
But it's not a unique
product of transposition.
In fact, you could--
if you are given
some order of objects
and you're asked to rearrange
them by transposition,
you may do them in
different order.
So the product is not
uniquely determined.
The product is,
in fact, you could
find somebody that does a
permutation with some number
of transpositions
and another person
with another set
of transpositions.
But one thing that
has to happen--
and it's always the
same-- is that the number
of transpositions is the
same [INAUDIBLE] two.
That is, if you find that to
get a permutation you need
an even number of
transpositions,
everybody else will need also an
even number of transpositions.
If you find an odd
number of transpositions,
everybody will find an odd
number of transpositions.
And that's kind of
clear if you have--
if you've achieved
the desired order
by doing some number
of transpositions,
you can add two
more transpositions
and not change anything.
You can flip two objects
and flip them back.
So this is a pretty
important result as well.
So it means that permutations
are either even or are odd.
So permutations
are even, if built
with an even number
of transpositions
or odd if built with an odd
number of transpositions.
So two kinds of permutations,
even permutations
or odd permutations.
So all these things
we've kind of
seen with this
permutation group.
There's one more thing
that is necessary to note.
Something that may have
seemed that coincidence there.
In fact, the 3 on the
right are transpositions.
And they're a single
transposition each.
So each one of those on the
right is an odd permutation.
It's built with
one transposition.
On the other hand, the other
ones are even transpositions,
the first three.
The first one is built
with zero transpositions
but the others are built
with two transpositions.
It's something you could
just see in detail.
In fact, I would
say it's worth doing
the table of multiplication
of this group.
But that coincidence is,
in fact, true in any--
in sn, in the group sn, the
number of even permutations
is equal to the number
of odd permutations.
Some pretty nice result.
There's equal numbers of even
and odd permutations in
any permutation group.
Actually, it's surprisingly
simple to show that.
You think of the even
permutations here-- here are
the even permutations.
And here are the
odd permutations.
And you can easily
show that there
is equal number on this one.
So let do it.
One way is to take the
permutation element.
So suppose you have
a permutation--
how should I call it--
p21.
You leave everything the
same but you have p21.
That permutes the
second and first labels.
Since it's an n group, the
rest are left invariant,
so 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
And you say, this maps
any permutation here
into a permutation there.
Why?
Because if you have an
even permutation here,
any element here has an even
number of transient mutations,
of transpositions.
So this is another
transposition,
it transposes 2 and 1.
So when you multiply
an element here by p21,
if it has an even number
of transpositions,
now it has an odd one.
So it must land somewhere here.
So any-- this p21
maps the even--
the even permutations
to the odd permutations.
Moreover, it maps them in
what's called 1 to 1 fashion.
If you have two permutations
here that are different,
it will map to two permutations
here that are different.
Why?
Because suppose you have here
pi and pj, two permutations.
1 is mapped to p21 pi, and
the other is map to p21 pj.
But if pi and pj
are different, two
permutations here,
I and j, pi and pj.
And if they are
different, then it
follows that these two are
different as well after you
multiply them by p21.
Why?
Because if they were
equal, p21 has an inverse.
It is itself p21, so you
could multiply them in.
And then you would show
that pi is equal to pj.
And that can't happen.
So two different
elements here will
go to two different
elements there.
So if you think of all
your elements here, go--
if you have 20 elements here,
they go to 20 elements here.
The only thing that can happen
is that some elements are not
reached here.
That would mean that these
two sets are not the same.
So you need to show that
this map reaches everybody.
So this shows it's
a one to one map.
And in fact, it's
kind of a joke,
but in a way to think
of this, one to one
really means two to
two, in the sense
that two things
go to two things.
So it's kind of a
funny name, one to one.
So the other thing
is that you need
to show that everybody reaches.
So the map is--
let's call surjective,
everybody reaches.
So it's clear that
everybody reaches
because if you have a pk
in here, permutation pk,
this pk can be written as
p21 times p21 times pk.
Because p21 times p21 is 1.
And this pk, since this
was an odd permutation,
this is an even one.
And then you've shown
that pk is obtained
by acting with p21 on
some even permutation.
So you'll reach.
So the map is surjective.
And therefore these two
things are the same.
They're identical numbers of
even and odd permutations,
a very nice fact
about these groups.